[Music]
go to the fart one
hey guys guys today i'm gonna be showing
you a day in the life of a girl who
sells her farts in a jar so i like to
get things rolling with some beans a
protein muffin sometimes even a yogurt
less sugar is better
some hard-boiled eggs and today i
decided i was going to make myself a
protein shake with some yogurt added to
it and oh i was feeling it for sure
while i wait for those parts to develop
i like to read
what the [__] and then after i'm ready
to go i go ahead and you know do my work
do my job i don't need to show you that
guys but i like to add in little flower
petals i feel like they attach the scent
and make it last longer and when i'm
finally finished with my jar i like to
leave a personalized note i want to
thank you so much the 97 take the flower
petal out
yeah yeah that's not what this is about
yeah what are you doing making it smell
nicer like i buy these farts for a
reason you know yeah dude
i want it to smell as ass in there as
possible exactly
can it really stay in there i some some
there was didn't we watch some tick tock
of some kid like fermenting his like he
farted in a jar jar and then like kept
it for like weeks and like apparently
it's
like and it just like soaked into the
glass and [__] so it like lasted a long
time so you could go you could do
pickled farts i guess
okay well he he like as a prank opened
it up and would like just take it around
school and like put it in people's noses
like it was like one of the worst things
i've ever smelled so
or they were coming from it
and that's right yeah yeah couldn't
handle it yeah if i walk into the ship
one day with a [__] jar start running
i will i don't think you should
advertise this i mean i guess you should
because it gets you more customers but
like don't don't like shoot it like a
vlog a day in the life of somebody who
sells their farts i think it makes the
product feel good less attractive yeah
yeah if i if anything i think you should
advertise gluttony you wake up and it's
just like
mounds of food that are unrecognizable
yeah yeah yeah what's what sound of
crushed orange chicken yeah exactly yeah
what's up with the less sugar is better
i was not eat a bunch of sugar yep
eat as much as you can
i want some nasty [__]
yeah it's too put together a little
protein powder little beans that's
regular aspartame yeah get some scent in
there this morning i'm eating a pound of
pickled daikon there we go yeah yeah
yeah ten
raw cloves of garlic i'm just gonna chew
those and swallow them and i know it's
coming are you guys gate keeping fart
sales yes yeah
yes we are yeah you know but you know
maybe people want this you know they
want that uh they want that lighter feel
to the fart you know yeah maybe yeah
yeah that's your clientele yeah it's
like healthy i want green farts yeah
they want the goop version of farts
right now what what is someone who buys
this what is the opening process and the
smelling process and the consumption
process look like depends on are they
jerking off or what depends
that's what kind of grade of glass
they're using and if the top is cork or
plastic you know it's just a
just something i read about no but
that's a genuine question like what are
they
like i don't know i don't know like this
is a sexual thing obviously so is the
smell what gets you going or is that
something you use as like a finishing
move you know
you know you get it to push the puke
yeah yes exactly
also is this like a party popper like
it's one time use i don't know like you
just pop
and the smell is out you're like well
[__] now i gotta read up god damn it
that's not really good for the
environment yeah seriously is it uh is
it like a top off does she have any more
tick tocks at all why don't you go to
her website how much are these parts
actually though you should actually buy
a couple relax
i mean one
it would actually be fun
i don't want to share it would be
hilarious to buy one of these and smell
it as though
sure a bonus cold open
how much are these man
what's the what's the value of a fart
man what's that one
what don't buy one
no i'm gonna start selling mine
wait who where does it say that click
that thousand dollars in one week
selling my jars a fart what and ever
since 50k
i've been getting a lot of questions
such as how long do the farts last did i
really fart 97 times in two days who
buys my farts and why and what are some
of my tips
and tricks
so the first question i get yeah those
are just the questions i'm getting
how long do the farts last and the smell
is most prominent for the first two days
but as i like to say one with makes
memories that last a lifetime
pause she's got a marketing like slogan
if she has some type of like you know
[__]
kfc 24 spices like combo that you you
know what i'm saying like she's like she
has like a chick-fil-a sauce of farts
yeah she's got like a special brand like
that's very impressive
okay she can like bust ass and she like
whips it she's like
need more of need more of this yeah yeah
maybe that's
maybe that's why she doesn't do gluttony
because it's a very calculated process
or she does that for a certain clientele
yeah like if they're like listen i want
you to just like that's like eat as much
ramen as possible
that's the [__] uh that's the hash
brand of her yeah yeah exactly
concentrate yes that's the wax yeah yeah
it comes in small little if you just get
a little
yeah do a dab you have to do that one as
a dab
you have to take a blow torch and heat
it up yeah underneath and then you open
it
trust me dude if you if you do two hits
of this you're gonna be [__] off dude
my third name was stank amato for a
second
dude what
90 day fiance cast member wow all right
let's let's see how much a fart i just
want to know the price of a fart yeah
what's the price of one
how much for this click your website
right there
uh uh okay okay so um yeah what if we
buy a whole crate of farts that's cool
right
great
did you sell pallets you sell pallets uh
that'd be [__] uh that'd be [__]
kick ass right did you do wholesale oh
is that kendall yeah uh um uh oh you're
thinking of greg yeah uh well um i
think that smelling farts is isn't that
weird i would like to smell your fart if
that would be okay with you
how much how much
a thousand dollars oh that's it let's
cop
so i was right she's doing a cyber
monday sale
half off
50 farts is kind of a lot dude wait is
she fifth she farts 50 times into one
jar did yeah no no no
one oh oh okay
oh you're saying because she made 50
grand so it's 50 jars of farts i see so
that means she only does like 25 farts
dude that's not that bad at all it's not
how do you control the the product
though
what if you let out like a double shot
that's wasted money yeah true you got to
mark that one up yeah this is a two
shotter yeah
four grand [__] that's a double shotter
though no she just gets heart spray yeah
there's like a fart spray
oh yeah okay it's in an episode no one's
listening but on the [__] new find
that link i do a covid test and i put
fart spray
in a jar in every episode i'm like oh
guys we got to make sure we have a safe
set can you pull out your covet test and
everyone always said they're like
[Laughter]
that's what we could do though yeah
that's what cash is saying is that we
can just get farts for a [__] yeah dude
that's what i'm saying we gotta find
scams like this everyone's scamming
everyone everyone is scamming this it's
[__] up yeah dude
we gotta we gotta set up a store in
decentraland where you can digitally buy
the farts and then you get one mailed to
you let's open up a fart dispensary
we'll sell all kinds of farts all
different brands different strengths and
indica yeah this one's more of a head
part yeah this one's more of a body part
yeah this one will make you puke this
one makes you think yeah
we also have um fart soda and bark bars
and fart gummies birdie bots every
flavored beans
but they're all [__] flavored
literally every bean in this thing
tastes like [__] this is actual poo
this is just straight up a turd in a jar
that's her next thing i think selling
poo selling his little turds oh
i mean i was that that different from
farting it's not
it's not that different no i'm just like
excited
oh [__] yeah [__] yeah dude i can't wait
that goes to hell oh hell yeah bro
you dropped new super stream drops new
droppings
new droppings
you have a [__] digital store in
decentraland and you just have a bunch
of [__] kids and supreme clothes
in their valve indexes just waiting in
line to get a fart yeah this season's
gonna be crazy yeah i heard all she ate
are red lentils
[Laughter]
oh dude limited runs from gwyneth
paltrow
didn't she do that a candlelit it was
like my fart yeah oh i thought she did a
[__] candle she did but i think she did
other ones too oh no no one that smells
like my orgasm that's what it was
what does that what am i like i don't
know sweat squirt yeah sweat squirt like
a little bit of gooch musk you know just
smells like [__] yeah it smells like
[__] 20 minutes of sex you know
yeah that's never that good of a smell
smells like sex in here smells like
pubes
someone little like a big o candle i
feel like that would just like
turn me feral like the hairs on the back
of my neck would stand up i'd be like
what's going on in here
the smell of sex i think would just make
me like
like like
like just it's instinctual yeah that is
like primal [__] yeah god makes you
want to eat ribs yeah yeah like
what this makes you want to go to kind
of sex are you having
i don't know just make sure you want to
be like filthy like
eating ribs all right [__] what was
the guy's name
from [__]
call me by your name yeah what
not timothy the other guy oh all right
army hammer cannibalism jesus yeah come
here timothy let me eat your little ribs
yeah
dude that's who's posting all that
that's who's posting all the posts on
the facebook fan group
it's army hammer's ghost account
bro did you see that video where it was
like the scene from calling me by your
name where he's like kissing
timothy shalom's feet and it was like he
improved this
yeah
yeah was he nibbling on them too
i don't
um
i love your little pig
ass bite at the top
oh
[Laughter]
don't break character timmy you're
[__] with my vibe i'm in the zone
someone get timothy get him back in the
zone
i'm losing my boner
what
cut you're not supposed to be hard
during the scene i don't know man big o
candle i feel like i just want to turn
the heat up in my place to like 85 and
eat a rack of ribs yeah
just like
something just like
all i'm saying i'm in the heat yeah we
just put meat yeah in heat that's what i
mean it's like it would like put me in
like a weird primal like
i wouldn't know what would happen you
know what i'm saying yeah i feel like a
weird pheromone would release and just
be like let's go hunt fish
fish yeah
why fish dude
you can spearfish yeah yeah yeah it's
like one with the earth [__] let's
[__] kill a fish with carrots
oh no i'm not i'm not do it i'm not do
it once not all i'm good you brought it
up
let me tell you something
[Laughter]
oh do that in a jar you'll be able to
sell that for sure what up i'm noelle
used to be a comedian um and now i just
sell fish moans in a jar of fish
they just open up a little jar this is
my day in the life of a guy who sells
fish mounds in a jar i start the morning
with a little green tea you know i like
to lube up the throat a little bit a
little honey a little honey make sure it
comes out nice and smooth
as simple as this
and that's i started a thousand dollars
right there i start by killing a puffer
fish with carrots
it's just the noise just to match the
tone it's just it's dying in front of me
i'm like
[Music]